kharkiv eigentlich ein bedeutendes
wissenschafts und bildungszentrum des
landes eigentlich eine studentenstadt
innerhalb von wenigen tagen hat sich die
zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine in ein
trümmerfeld verwandelt bilder von dem
raketenangriff auf das
verwaltungsgebäude wenige tage nach
kriegsbeginn schockieren die ganze welt
gezielt haben russische truppen versucht
das regionale verwaltungsgebäude zu
zerstören auch der vorplatz ist von
mehreren raketeneinschlägen vollkommen
verwüstet unser reporter sebastian
travel hat den ort mit dem einst
prachtvollen gebäude jetzt besucht wir
stehen im innenhof des
verwaltungsgebäudes von kharkiv hier
sind am anfang des krieges von drei
raketen eingeschlagen und wenn wir uns
diese zerstörung einmal anschauen
dann sehen wir hier ein auto das ist
völlig versiegt von granatsplittern und
von schrapnell und hier vorne ist etwas
besonders grausames passiert hier muss
ein mensch gestanden haben als diese
rakete den innenhof getroffen hat man
sieht immer noch die blutspuren die hier
diesen schacht hinunter gelaufen sind
[Musik]
die rakete die ist hier vorne auf diesen
platz eingeschlagen und die verwüstung
sieht man hier im ganzen gebäude wenn
wir jetzt hier weiter gehen überall
schutt und asche betontrümmern
stahlrohre
holzstühle und hier unten klafft ein
riesengroßes loch der wucht dieses
einschlag sehr lässt sich hier wirklich
nur erahnen das ist unbeschreiblich
man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen dass
das mal ein prachtvolles gebäude gewesen
ist
und im übrigen natürlich auch kein
militärisches ziel das ist ein
verwaltungsgebäude in dem zivilisten
gearbeitet haben
was wir jetzt sehen das ist das büro
gewesen des gouverneurs von rajiv
schränke sind zertrümmert wurden ein
fernseher liegt da
die decke kommt teilweise
herunter es sind überall trümmerteile
der raum sehen wir jetzt sehen ist das
pressecenter hier haben
pressekonferenzen stattgefunden man
sieht dass hier noch diese stoffe
sitzreihen
trümmerteile hängen von der decke die
fenster sind zerborsten hier weht ein
eisiger wind jetzt durch das gebäude
ja wir sehen hier im obersten stockwerk
blutverschmierte türen
und mitarbeiter müssen nach dieser
katastrophe noch mal wieder gekommen
sein um hier blumen niederzulegen die
hier zwischen den trümmern zwischen den
splittern und dem ganzen staub liegen
der angriff auf die einzige
millionenstadt nimmt kein ende
der haken fliegt unter dauerbeschuss wir
hören hier im sekundentakt heftige
explosionen und dieses gebiet was wir da
sehen das wird hier von den russen in
schutt und asche gelegt wir haben auch
hinweise darauf dass die russen
streubomben einsetzen und das ist über
bewohntem gebiet verboten das ist ein
kriegsverbrechen und das ist putin egal
offensichtlich er bombardiert hier die
zivilbevölkerung ungefähr eine million
menschen sollen die stadt mittlerweile
verlassen haben über 500.000 die zittern
hier in ihren kellern um ihr leben
trümmer und tote beben der erde dort wo
einmal familien wohnten das ist die neue
realität in kharkiv die einst so
pulsierende stadt ist kampfgebiet kein
tag ohne bomben raketen und granaten